it is it is official the uk is in
recession and
it's not just any recession it's a fall
of
20.4 percent uh in gross domestic
products uh in the second quarter
alone so over the lockdown period that
is an unprecedented
number we have literally never seen
anything
like that in terms of the scale of the
fall
in the economy it is the biggest
recession that the uk has
ever faced in terms of depth since
gdp was invented basically back in the
1930s and you
even if you go back to the 1920s which
is the period that we have quarterly
numbers for
we've never seen anything like that
before now none of this will necessarily
come
as a massive surprise we all know that
knew this was going to be a very big
fall
in gross domestic product but the scale
of it to put it into context
is greater than we've seen in any other
g7 economy so among france the u.s
other major economies like germany
they've all had very big falls in gdp
but mostly it's been around the kind of
10
percent the early teens 13.8 in france
20 is far greater than that and that's
what we've just
received from the ons so it is a
recession that
is a kind of relatively arbitrary term
in economics to say that any two period
of
where you have two quarters of
contraction and we did we had minus 2.2
in the first quarter and now it's minus
20.4 is a recession but as i say
this is unlike any recession we've ever
seen in british uh
or indeed global history uh and that's
for a couple of reasons obviously the
depth of it the scale of it
is absolutely enormous but secondly and
perhaps most importantly this is a
recession that was brought on
partly by those lock down measures uh to
try to keep the virus
under control the big question now is
whether there can be any bounce back
uh in the next few quarters and we'll be
delving through those numbers to get a
sense of whether there are early signs
of that at the moment
it's more or less in line with what
economists had expected
but nonetheless it just when you look at
this we were all expecting
a very big fall indeed but just to see
it in black and white there
when you look at the numbers that are
just out from the office for national
statistics i have to keep looking at it
to
remind myself it's real 20.4
we've literally never seen anything like
it before
you